Thank you.
Members take their seats.
The House will be in order.
Hear ye!
This day, December 4, 2024, the first Wednesday of December, being the day designated by the Constitution, Part 2, Article 3 for the Assembling of the Body, the 169th General Court of the State of New Hampshire at the Capitol in the City of Concord, I do hereby convene the 2025 House of Representatives and call the House to order.
The members-elect will rise and be reverently attentive while guest chaplain, Reverend Jean Beniste, rector of St.
Paul's Episcopal Church in Concord leads us in prayer.
Good morning.
I'm glad to be here again with you and this morning today to lead you in invocation and prayer.
For some of you who do not know me, I want to just make a quick introduction.
I am Reverend Jean Sebenist.
I am the director, senior priest at your neighbor church, St.
Paul's Episcopal Church.
I am a native of Haiti.
I'm glad to be here with you.
Now let us take a moment of reflection and reverence as we gather in this place of of service and governance.
Almighty Creator, source of all wisdom and understanding, we gather today as representatives of the people, born by our shared responsibility to serve, guide, and afflict the state.
We seek your blessing as we begin this work.
To the divine of all faith, be you called God, the Almighty, the Great Spirit, or by other names.
We ask for your guidance in our deliberation.
the Almighty, the Great Spirit, or by other name.
We ask for your guidance and our deliberations.
God has wisdom to make decisions that reflect unity, justice, compassion, and peace.
and fill our heart with humility so we may listen deeply and respect the diverse voices and perspectives surrounding us.
Help us act with integrity and courage as we seek the common good of all.
May we be reminded in this moment of reflection that we are all interconnected, part of the same human family.
And that every action we take as a ripple effect upon our communities, our children, and the generation to come.
Bless our work today and every day so that we may govern with fairness, empathy, and love for all people.
We God bless of grace.
so that we may govern with fairness, empathy, and love for all people, regardless of race, gender, creed, or circumstance.
May the peace be upon you all.
Please remain standing while Representative-elect James Tebow from Franklin leads us in the Pledge of Allegiance.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the Republic for which it stands, one nation, under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
Please remain standing while the members of the Goffstown High School Honors Chorus sings our national anthem.
Thank you.
Oh, say can you see by the dawn's early light.
What so proudly we hailed at the twilight's last gleaming, whose broad stripes and bright stars through the perilous night.
O'er the ramparts we watched were so gallantly streaming?
And the rocket's red glare, the bombs bursting in air, Gave proof through the night that our flag was still there.
Oh, say does that soft-spangled banner yet wave for the land of the free and the home of the brave.
Thank you.
The House will attend to request for leaves of absence.
Mr.
Speaker, the day, illness, representatives Coker, Dylan Germana, Molly Howard, Panik, and Scully.
The day, important business, representatives Flanagan, Kofalt, and Taylor.
The day, death in the family, representatives Bochman and Judy.
These leaves of absence shall be granted unless otherwise ordered by the House.
The House will attend to the introduction of guests.
Please remain seated until the completion of the introduction of guests.
Thank you.
Mr.
Speaker, please welcome Colonel Eric Power, U.S.
Air Force retired, Ryan Power, and Deborah Brissett, husband, son, and sister of Representative-elect Power.
Rebecca Ann Wheeler and Benjamin MacArthur, guests of Representative-elect Wheeler.
Rosemary Orr, wife of Representative-elect Orrs.
Susie and Gary Miller, Linnea Hartziker, parents and wife of Representative-elect Miller.
Ann Pearson, wife of Representative-elect Wayne Pearson.
Joy and Alex Nelavanko and Mark Mastrosinke, wife, son, and guest of Representative-elect Nelavanko.
Catherine Turrer and Liz McConnell, wife and guest of representative-elect Turrer.
Mary Ann Genesian, wife of representative-elect Genesian.
Madeline Mandelbaum, mother of representative-elect Mandelbaum.
Ted and Jack Barbour, Haley and Baker Brown, husband, son and daughter of and grandson of representative-elect Barbour.
Kimberly and Hannah Kesselring, wife and daughter of Representative-elect Kesselring.
Louise Bausher, Marie Wallace, and Richard Credian, siblings of Representative-elect Credian.
Amanda Whibby, guest of Representative-elect DuPont.
Joseph Reinfurt and Cassie LaVallerie, husband and daughter of Representative-elect Reinfurt.
Michael and Cecilia Pitaro, guests of Representative- representative elect Pataro.
Linda Peoples, Linda Jacobson and Jacob McQuestin, wife and guest of representative elect Peoples.
Michael Murphy, Susan R.
Scott and Kenneth Steiner, husband and guests of representative elect Mary Murphy.
Kimberly Hartnett, wife of representative elect Hartnett.
Dana, Donna Crystal Miles, guests of Representative-elect Miles.
Nelson Long, father of Representative-elect Patrick Long.
Stephen Corzon and Dorothea Abbott, husband and mother of Representative-elect Corzon.
Jerry Mitchell, wife of Representative-elect Snodgrass.
Shana O'Rourke, Gabriel Beckwith, Kirk and Eleanor Callender, Erin and Brianna Dameron, guests of Representative-elect O'Rourke.
and the candidates.
and Shannon Carey, guests of representative elect Mazur.
Sarah Healy and Hannah Parker, guests of representative elect Reed.
Steve, Sandy, Aiden, and Annabelle Morse, parents and children of representative elect Morse.
Jerry, Josh, and Becca DeLimas, and Rosie Allaire, husband and children of representative elect DeLimas.
Billy Preza, mother of representative elect Preza.
Erin Fract Monroe and Mary F, guests of Representative-elect Fract.
Kayla, Charles, Jameson, Dawn, and Sarah Dumont, Brenda Whitelis, and Jerry Pellegrini, guests of Representative-elect Dumont.
James Raven, guest of Representative-elect Elberger.
Mary Beth Wadlinger, Steve and Gail Johnson, Steve and Christy Bravo, and Paige Brenner, guests of Representative-elect Petdernell.
Helene Weary, wife of Representative-elect Weary.
Jack Boyle, guests of Representative-elect Simpson.
Matthew and John Henry DeVito and Russell Green, husband and sons of Representative-elect DeVito.
Jacob, Sarah, and Tisra Georges, Jordan and Ethan Kadima, Glory McKendie, Angel Kepinga, Crisp Malaylay, and Victorine Munzimi and Shirley Tomlinson, guests of Representative-elect George's.
Brandi Swanson, wife of Representative-elect Swanson.
Aletta Brown and Destiny Davis, guests of Representative-elect Fred Davis.
Cara Dunn, wife of Representative-elect Dunn.
John Perez, husband of Representative-elect Perez.
Nellie Palmer, wife of Representative-elect Palmer.
Norma Sutcliffe, Josh Blake, Liam Drake, James Howard, and Max Ringelstein, grandmother and guests of Representative-elect Tebow.
Jason, Benjamin, Eliana Talurski, husband and children of Representative-elect Talurski.
Dennis, Debra, Joseph, and Ava Tenzar, guests of Representative-elect Tenzar.
Jeanne Safran and Steve Grill, guests of Representative-elect Grill.
Linda Hunt, wife of Representative-elect Hunt.
Chris Manos and Julia Golem, brother and daughter of Representative-elect Manos.
Anna Kingston and Mark Millett, mother and husband of Representative-elect Paquette.
Jamila Gathright Scales, Gloria Timmons, Jamila Ashanti Scales, John James Jackson, Gina Spleen, and Akira Shaw, guests of Representative-elect Harriet Gathright.
Elizabeth Thomas and Michelle Barrett, wife and guest of Representative-elect Doug Thomas.
Anthony Henry, Sean Morency, and Donovan, guests of representative elect Leon.
Verde Packard, sister of representative elect Packard.
The honorable Maria Perez, former member from Milford, guest of representative elect Alexander.
The honorable Corinne Morse, former member from Canaan, guest of representative elect Opal.
The Honorable Emily Phillips, former member from Fremont, guest of representative elect Noble.
And the Honorable Sherry Gold, former member from Bradford, guest of representative elect Panic.
They are with us in the gallery today.
Welcome to the New Hampshire House.
Gracias.
The House will now attend to a communication.
In a letter dated Monday, December 2nd, Hello Mr.
Clerk Smith.
I am writing to let you know that I am going to forego my position as State Representative for District 12 in New Hampshire because I am moving out of my district as of December 31st.
I will not come over to be sworn in and I will not be serving as the representative that I was elected to be for this district.
I do hope to help out in other ways in my new district down the road.
Thank you for your help, Don Evans.
This resignation is accepted with regret.
We will now begin the process of the roll call.
This roll call is done alphabetically by county.
I will begin with Belknap County.
If you have a similar or same name as another member from a different county, please be mindful of which county I am announcing when I say your name.
If there are two with the same name in the same county, I will say their first name first.
A couple of bullet points before I begin, however.
You are seated where you are supposed to be today.
You will find your oath slips either in front of you, in your seat pockets, or underneath you.
If you look to your front and you do not have an oath slip there, then please check underneath your seat because it is likely there.
If there is a problem in a little while and for whatever reason you don't have that oath slip, which I will find extremely hard to believe because myself and Paul Bryan put them there yesterday afternoon, then we will print a new one for you.
Do not sign them until I tell you to, please.
If anyone comes in during the process of the roll call and misses the vote, excuse me, and misses my calling their name, please send them down to me at the conclusion and I will record them as present.
We will begin with Belknap County.
Please answer here or something else affirmatively responding loudly so that I may hear you.
Belknap County.
Aldrich.
Here.
Bean.
Bogert.
Here.
Boards.
Coker.
Bogert.
Bords.
Coker.
Comtois.
Dumais.
Freeman.
Harvey Bolia.
Lunny.
Minor.
Nagel.
Ploge.
St.
Nagel.
Plogier.
St.
Clair.
Terry.
Toner.
Trottier.
Varney.
Carroll County.
Avelani.
Belcher, Brown, Bucco, Burroughs, Cordelli, Crawford, Hamblin, McDonald, McAleer, Page, Page, here, Petternell, here, Smith, Taylor, Taylor, Woodcock, here, Cheshire County, Ames, here, Ames, thank you, Birch.
Here.
Faulkner.
Fox.
Here.
Dillard.
Ames, thank you.
Birch, Faulkner, Fox, Dylan Germana, Dylan Germana, Nicholas Germana, Gruber, Harvey, Hunt, Jacobs, Jones, Karasinski.
Mattson.
Murphy.
Balavanco.
Newell.
O'Rourke.
Here.
Partial.
Qualley.
Here.
Rhodes.
Thaxton.
Here.
Weber.
Willette.
Here.
Tierney.
Valerino.
Here.
Berejni.
Bajelabrik.
Boulton.
Here.
Bullier, Berejni, Bajelabrik, Bolton, Corman, Fellows, Frocht, Franz, Haken Phillips, Ladd, Lewis Lovett Lucas McFarlane, Merhead, Opal, Rockmore, Sellers, Sparr, Stavis.
Stringham.
Sullivan.
Sykes.
Hillsborough County.
Alexander.
Ammon.
Barber.
Boeschman.
Alexander.
Ammon.
Barber.
Beauchemin.
Bergeron.
Bergeron?
Berry.
Beaum.
Bouras.
Bouchard.
Boyd.
I would have talked to you.
Here.
Boehm.
Bouros.
Bouchard.
Here.
Boyd.
Budutake.
Here.
Shereja.
Cretion.
Here.
Cocom.
Cole.
Here.
Corcoran.
Cornell.
Here.
Creighton.
Herecoran.
Cornell.
Creighton.
Daniels.
Darby.
Dargee.
Davis.
DeSylvestro.
Dolan.
Drew.
Dumont.
Here.
Drew.
Dumont.
Here.
DuPont.
Elberger.
Here.
Erf.
Fadolfi.
Here.
Flanagan.
Foss.
Here.
Fox.
Gagne.
Here.
Gagney.
Gorgias.
Representative like Gorgias.
Georges.
Gaiusen.
Gorski.
Gould, Greg, Griffin, Grill, Grund, Here.
Harriet Gathright.
Here.
Hartnett.
Hegner.
Here.
Herbert.
Grund, Harriet Gathright, Hartnett, Hegner, Herbert, Howard, Jack, Judy, Judy, Juris, Kelly, Kenny.
Kerwin.
Kesselring.
Kluger.
Kofalt.
LaBrie, Lascellas, Liebley, LeClerc, Leishman, Lloyd, Long, McKenzie, Tim Tim Mannion, Tom Mannion, Manahar, Mazur, McK Here.
McLean.
Here.
Miles.
Mooney.
Here.
Morton.
Mary Murphy.
Here.
Nancy Murphy.
Alessandra Murray.
Here.
Megan Murray., Sue Newman, Noble, Nauter, Om, Panic, Panic, Paquette.
Power.
Peoples.
Patrigno.
Plamondon.
Post.
Priess.
Priza.
Prue.
Prout.
Raymond, Reinfert, Rice, Rombo, Rung, Ryan, Salvi, Schneller, Scully, Scully, Sybert.
Seidel.
Sheehan.
Sirway.
Slautia.
Soffokitis.
Spear.
Staub.
Here.
Suter.
Swanson.
Here.
Talerski.
Spear, Staub, Suter, Swanson, Talersky, Tays, Tenzar, Thomas, Ulery, Vale, Veyu, Warden Wheeler Wary Wilhelm vayu warden wheeler wary wilhelm merrimack county andrews ors aylward boyd Here.
Ritchie.
Here.
Cambrils.
Kaplan.
Here.
Boyd.
Ritchie.
Cambrils.
Kaplan.
Colby.
Devoid.
Ebel.
Gallagher.
Gibbs.
Gonzalez.
Hall, Hicks, Hill, Kelly, Lane, Levitt, Luno, McKay, Carol Dan McGuire.
Dan McGuire, Mahegan, Moffett, Morse, Newsome, Payor, Pataro, Plant, Polozov.
Here.
Richards.
Raisner.
Here.
Sergeant.
Schamberg.
Present.
Schultz.
Here.
Seaworth.
See.
Here.
Snodgrass.
Susie.
Here.
Tebow.
Walner.
Here.
Walsh.
Wood.
Yes, sir.
Woods.
Thank you.
We have a wood in the woods, would you believe?
Rockingham County.
Balboni.
Ball.
Bennett.
Bernardi.
Bridal.
Brown.
Briar.
Cahill.
Bernardi Bridal Brown Breyer Cahill DeVries DeSimone DeVito Dolan Donnelly Doucette Drago Dunn Edgar Edwards Thank you.
Guthrie, Kuzovsky, Harb, Haskins, Janigian, Katsikoris, Kahn, Nab, Kutab, Leon, Litchfield, Love, Lundgren, Lynn, McDonald, Majury, Malloy, Mandelbaum, Manion Manos Markle McDonald McGrath McMahon Melvin, Muse, Muse, Mills, Minor, Munns, Present.
Murray.
Here.
Nadeau.
Nelson.
Here.
Osborne.
Packard.
Here.
Page.
Pearson.
Mark.
Here.
Pearson-Steven.
Perez.
Here.
Popovici-Muller.
Aye.
Porcelli.
Here.
Petucic.
Prudhomme O'Brien.
Here.
Reynolds.
Reed.
Here.
Roy.
Sabarin Ditchwine.
Here.
Shurer?
Selby?
Here.
Simpson?
Sorenson?
Here.
Sody?
Spillane?
Here.
Summers?
Here, Sweeney, SciTech, Thomas, Trip, Tudor, Here.
Here.
Terrer.
Valone.
Here.
Vandy Castile.
Verville.
Here.
Vose.
Walsh.
Here.
Ward.
Vandica Steele, Verville, Vose, Walsh, Ward, Weinstein, Weiler, Wilson, Stratford County, Ankerberg, Bailey, Bay, Bixby, Burnham, Burton, Dede Poulin, DeLemis, DeRoy, England, Here.
Farrington.
Here.
Gilmore.
Granger.
Aye.
Hall.
Here.
Harrington.
Oregon.
Gilmore, Granger, Hall, Harrington, Horrigan, Horrigan, Howard, Howland, Johnson, Kaczynski, Here.
LaMontagnechelle, Levesque, Malone, Miller, Pearson, Potenza, Schmidt Selig Jeffrey Smith Marjorie Smith, Southworth, Stone, Turcotte, Wade, Walker, Wall, Sullivan County Judy Aaron Michael Aaron, Cluedier, Damon, Dry, Gerard, Grant, Hemingway Palmer Rollins Smith Spillsbury.
Here.
Sullivan.
If any member came in after I began the roll call, please come down and see me so that we might mark you off.
Please give us a moment of patience while we tally for our official number.響鐘 .
.
Thank you.響鐘 Thank you.
Gracias.
Thank you.
With 389 members-elect having answered the call, a quorum is present.
The chair, on behalf of the House, will now appoint a committee to wait upon the Governor and Executive Council to inform them that a quorum of the House is assembled and requests their attendance.
In keeping with tradition, the chair appoints, from Concord, the of the House Representative-elect Mary Jane Wallner serving her 23rd term.
The chair further appoints the member from Ringe, Representative-elect Hunt, serving his 20th term in the New Hampshire House.
The chair further appoints from Madbury, Representative-elect Janet Wall, serving her 20th term in the House.
And finally, the member from Derry, Representative-elect Phyllis Katzikoury, is serving her 20th term in the New Hampshire House.
The Sergeant-at-Arms will escort the committee to the Governor's Council Chambers.
Thank you.
Gracias.
The chair recognizes the acting sergeant at arms.
Mr.
Chair, the Honorable Executive Counsel.
Thank you.
The chair recognizes the acting sergeant at arms.
Mr.
Chair, his excellency, please sign it and you will pass it to your left for collection by my staff.
I now have the pleasure to introduce for the last time to administer the oath of office, the governor of the state of New Hampshire, Christopher T.
Sununu.
Good morning.
I'm taking a picture.
I've got to get my picture.
I just want to remember that Jason Osborne didn't wear a tie.
No, I'm just kidding.
I'm just kidding.
Well, it is great to see everybody here back in session to kick it off.
First, wholeheartedly, on behalf of myself and the Executive Council, congratulations to all those who ran great races.
A huge thank you to all the families that are joining us because as they have all learned, if they haven't learned already, campaigns stink.
Campaigns can be really, really hard.
They're a grind.
They're so important, but they can be really hard on families sometimes.
And again, I was saying this, and I think I say it every other year, there is really no place, no place in this entire country where you have a legislative body so dedicated to service, regardless of party, political affiliation, philosophy.
We all know you ain't doing it for the paycheck, right?
So it really is, and that's something that is an amazing checks and balance, an amazing driver of community involvement and engagement, that it is truly a volunteer legislature, the largest of its kind anywhere to be found.
And if you do the math, 400 representatives for only 1.4 million people, it is truly the most representative body of government on the face of planet Earth.
And that's an amazing thing to take a long time in.
I think it gives everybody a lot of confidence.
And even when we don't get it exactly right, and every once in a while government doesn't get it exactly right, it's still way better than everybody else.
So that's the important part.
So I'll ask all the members of the House of Representatives to raise your right hand and please repeat after me.
I state your name of your city or town do solemnly swear that I will bear faith in true allegiance to the United States of America and the state of New Hampshire and and will support the constitutions thereof.
and will support the constitutions thereof.
So help me God, I state your name.
Do solemnly and sincerely swear and affirm that I will faithfully and impartially discharge and perform all the duties incumbent upon me as State Representative according to the best of my abilities, agreeably to to the rules and regulations of this Constitution and the laws of the state of New Hampshire.
So help me God.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
and pass them to your left, and my staff will come and retrieve them up the aisles.
You can sit.
Thank you.
Gracias.
.
Will representatives Mcdonnell and Wheeler please come to the front to see me for a moment.
Thank you.
McDonnell and Wheeler, please come to the front to see me for a moment.
Gracias.
Have all members passed in their oath sheets?
Thank you.
The House will come to order.
The chair has proposed ground rules for the election of speaker, which have been reviewed by those candidates for speaker and they have been printed in your House calendar.
Representatives Packard and Simpson move the adoption of the ground rules for election.
The question is on the adoption of those ground rules.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
All those opposed nay.
The ayes have it and the rules for election have been adopted.
Before I begin the nominations for speaker I just wanted to explain how speeches are timed.
The chair keeps a stopwatch.
The time starts when a member starts talking and stops when they stop talking.
Their walk down time does not count, just for clarification.
Nominations for speaker of the New Hampshire House of Representatives are in order.
The chair recognizes the member from Walpole, Representative Lucy Weber, for the purpose of making a nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Clerk.
I rise today to nominate Representative Alexis Simpson for Speaker of the New Hampshire House.
For those of you who do not know her, Representative Simpson brings a wealth of life experience to her work in the legislature.
She has a bachelor's degree in physics and master's degrees in divinity and theology.
She's worked in agricultural policy and advocacy, focusing on sustainable agriculture.
And she is a pastor with all the complexities and responsibilities of that job, including pastoral counseling.
In her time in the House, Representative Simpson has served on the Environment and Agriculture Committee, the Judiciary Committee, and the Resources, Recreation, and Development Committee.
For the last two years, Representative Simpson has served as a minority leader here in the House.
As such, she has worked with members of both parties to ensure that the work of the New Hampshire House progresses smoothly.
She's familiar with all aspects and challenges of the job of Speaker.
We all see the Speaker weekly as the presiding officer of this body.
But there's so much more to the Speaker's job, ensuring that the committee process works smoothly, crafting of the biennial budget to the most deadlines, ensuring the decorum is preserved in this chamber and in the committee rooms.
Responsibility for the safety of the members of this body, the staff who work here, and the members of the general public.
The staff who work here, and the members of the general public.
of this body, the staff who work here, and the members of the general public.
Oversight of all of the functions of the legislative branch, working with the Senate, working with the legislative staff, both partisan and nonpartisan.
Oh, and the challenge of the management and preservation of three historic buildings with all their quirks, not to mention the ongoing construction just outside our windows of a new parking garage.
Representative Simpson has forged relationships with House members of both parties, with senators and with our legislative staff members.
She is able to bring people together to take groups with disparate interests and forge consensus.
She is uniquely qualified to identify the strengths each member brings to the work of the House and to create a climate in which members use the talents and experience they bring with them to the fullest and offering opportunities for members to develop the skills to take on new challenges.
Representative Simpson is particularly qualified to ensure that the House has run along principles of fairness, respect, and decorum for all members, majority and minority alike, fostering full and robust debates about policy while preserving an atmosphere of respect and collegiality.
Finally, Representative Simpson brings to a difficult job a sense of humor, a bit of humility, a great laugh, a sense of optimism, and an overwhelming enthusiasm for the work of this house and for the well-being of her colleagues.
I hope you will join me in voting for Alexis Simpson as our next House Speaker.
Thank you, Mr.
Clerk.
Representative Lucy Webber places the name of Representative Alexis Simpson in nomination for Speaker.
The chair recognizes the member from Milford, Representative Peter Petrigno, for the purpose of seconding the nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Clerk.
Colleagues, it is my honor to second the nomination of Reverend Alexis Simpson as our next speaker and to indulge her consideration in supporting her candidacy.
Alexis was first elected to this chamber 10 years ago, bringing a strong sense of social responsibility and a commitment to do good in service of the people of New Hampshire and her Rockingham district serving the towns of Exeter, Newsfields, New Market, and Stratum.
Now entering her fourth term, Alexis has been an effective and accomplished legislator, a member of the Resources, Recreation, and Development Committee, the Environment and Agriculture Committee, and the Judiciary Committee.
As the deputy Democratic leader, she has proven herself to work effectively, respectfully, and cooperatively, not only with leadership but with all, regardless of party.
In addition to being an experienced and dedicated legislator, Alexis is married, a mother of two teenage boys, and a caring, empathetic clergywoman, a person of integrity, veracity, and prayerfulness.
She holds a bachelor's degree in physics, a master's in divinity, and a master's in technology.
The work experience includes service as the executive director of the Waysmead Center United Campus Ministry to UNH, providing compassionate direct service to New Hampshire's seacoast and surrounding communities.
As the bridge pastor of the First Congregational Church in Hancock, andim Ministries in Greenland and Salem, just to name a few.
Alexis has dedicated herself to public service for the common good, both here in the People's House and in the Lord's House.
Colleagues, clearly Alexa Simpson brings legislative experience, institutional knowledge, leadership skills, and an honorable character which will lead us fairly and objectively.
Her thoughtful leadership style and strong moral ethical compass is one which unites people.
She will ensure decorum and be a leader for all House members.
I am confident that Alexis Simpson will provide us with the leadership you can trust.
And please join me in electing Alexis Simpson as our next speaker.
Thank you very much.
Representative Peter Petrigno seconds the nomination of Representative Alexis Simpson.
The chair recognizes the member from Exeter, Representative Alexis Simpson.
Thank you Mr.
Chair and thank you to the representatives from Walpole and Milford for those generous words.
Good morning, colleagues, and congratulations on being elected to the New Hampshire House.
Thank you for making the commitment to your constituents to serve Granite Staters and to spend the next two years making government work for the people of New Hampshire.
My name is Alexis Simpson, and I'm running to be the speaker of the New Hampshire House.
All of us arrived in our seats today from different paths.
Mine started when my older child was in fourth grade.
I first ran for State House then because, like many of you, I wanted to make the world, and particularly New Hampshire, a better place, a better place for him and for his classmates.
For me that meant making sure that they all had access to healthy local food because healthy food leads to healthy kids and healthy kids leads to healthy communities.
Here in New Hampshire we have a vibrant local food system that strengthens our rural communities and helps them thrive economically.
I still believe we could do more to encourage Thank you.
In New Hampshire, we have a vibrant local food system that strengthens our rural communities and helps them thrive economically.
I still believe we could do more to encourage our local food system and enliven our rural communities.
But it was 15 years ago that I helped start my own town's farm to school program, and I still maintain that vision and work toward that goal for our children and for our communities.
For several years, I sponsored farm-to-school legislation, and we finally passed a farm-to-school pilot program last year.
It was a bipartisan effort, as so much great legislation often is.
In my personal life, I continue to invest in local farms, including going out of my way, to buy local food and support producers from throughout our region.
Local food producers are, after all, small businesses, and without them, our local economies and communities would falter.
We all have stories that we come with this morning, stories that inspire the policy that we care so much about.
Maybe the policy that inspired you to run for office was making sure all Granite Staters can afford their housing.
Maybe it's to ensure students receive the services they need to obtain a high-quality education.
Maybe you want to keep your neighbors and your families safe.
Whatever it is, whatever bill you want to pass and send to the governor's desk, you cannot do it alone.
None of us Thank you.
and your families safe.
Whatever it is, whatever bill you want to pass and send to the governor's desk, you cannot do it alone.
None of us can.
We need to work together in this body to make the changes that we envision.
Today I'm running to be your next speaker of the house because we need a leader who can bring people together across differences to reach a common goal.
For 25 years I I have been a faith leader in my community.
Whether I was pastoring a church, working as a chaplain, running a spiritually based nonprofit, or teaching Sunday school, I bring people together around common values.
I've led interfaith work by understanding and considering others lives and identities.
I pride myself on being both collaborative and decisive, compassionate and data-driven.
I will listen to you and respect you, even if and when we view policies differently.
The next two years will be tough.
We're facing a difficult budget season.
We had a difficult time last time, too, but together we can do it when we center Granite State values.
Our constituents will be watching what we do here because it will affect their daily lives.
As the only woman in my university class to obtain a Bachelor of Science in Physics, and as the first woman minister in three rural churches before the age of 30, I'm used to working with and leading people who see the world differently than I do.
Yet I firmly believe you do not have to be the biggest bully or have the loudest voice to be a strong leader, to stand up for what is right for Granite Staters.
Your vote today will decide how this chamber, this body, this building will be led for the next two years.
As a legislator, as a leader, as a person, I stand strong in my core values while always recognizing that the person across the table from me, whether that person's on my side of the aisle or not, is a human being.
As speaker, I will make sure that we strive to respect each other in the hallways, the committee rooms, and through every floor speech and parliamentary inquiry.
We must hold tight to our own humanity and remember the humanity of each of our colleagues and our constituents through our actions here as New Hampshire lawmakers.
Today I'm ready to lead and stand beside you as we work to make New Hampshire a better place for all Granite Staters.
Throughout these next two years, the 400 of us gathered here had the opportunity and and more important, the responsibility, to make our state more affordable and more hospitable than it is now.
We can do this together.
When you receive your ballot, I ask for you to vote for Alexa Simpson for speaker.
Thank you.
The member from Exeter, Representative Alexis Simpson, has accepted her nomination.
Further nominations are in order.
The chair recognizes the member from Goffstown, Representative Lisa Mazur, for the purpose of making a nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Clerk.
Good morning, esteemed colleagues, members of this honorable chamber, and guests.
It is my privilege to rise today to nominate Sherman, Sherm, Packard, as Speaker of the New Hampshire House of Representatives.
For the past 34 years, Sherm has demonstrated unwavering commitment to the principles that define our great state.
Limited government, individual liberty, fiscal responsibility, and a deep respect for the voice of the people.
These values guide our work here in the Granite State and must shape the leadership of this chamber.
Sherm has proven to be a steadfast leader and a dedicated public servant.
With his extensive experience, he has championed legislation that supports parental rights, strengthens our economy, safeguards personal freedoms, and ensures that every tax dollar is spent wisely.
But more than policy, Sherm embodies the qualities of leadership we need at this critical juncture.
He listens to all perspectives, builds consensus, and upholds the dignity of this institution.
In an era where decisions often dominate, SHRM reminds us of the power of collaboration and respect.
As Speaker, SHRM will continue to lead with integrity, transparency, and a clear vision for the future.
He will keep his door open and ensure that this House remains a beacon of democracy.
He will support legislation that protects New Hampshire and preserves our live free or die way of life.
Make no mistake, as a result of his solid leadership, the committee to elect House Republicans was instrumental in securing a historic 44-seat working Republican majority in the House.
We are at a critical moment in New Hampshire's history.
The decisions we make in this chamber, even today, will impact the lives of our citizens for generations to come.
In the words of Sherm, and I quote, the key to our success is sticking together as one team.
And with that unity, we will continue to move New Hampshire forward, keeping it safe and free.
End quote.
I have no doubt that Sherman Packard, Sherm, is the right person to lead this House.
I urge my colleagues to support this nomination and to join me in electing Sherm Packard in nomination for speaker.
The chair recognizes the member from Hudson, Representative Kim Rice, for the purpose of seconding the nomination.
Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm sure you're thinking that the clerk clearly made a mistake.
But after a rather lively conversation and assurances that I can live with and that I I believe those that supported me can live with, I rise to second the nomination of Sherm Packer for Speaker of the House.
Thank you.
All right, everybody.
All right, thank you, everyone.
Thank you.
All right, everybody.
All right, thank you, everyone.
You know, I served under Sherm.
We have a great opportunity here.
We have a very large majority.
Let's do great things for the live free or die state.
I hope you'll join me in supporting Sherm packard for speaker of the house thank you representative kim rice seconds the nomination of representative sherman packard the chair recognizes the member from bedford representative tedorski, for the purpose of seconding the nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Clerk.
I stand in support in the nomination of Sharon Packard for the next Speaker of the House.
My support is not only as a state rep, but as my advocation as a leadership coach who has coached executives for close to 25 years worldwide.
There are three characteristics that I'd like to highlight about Sherm.
Number one, how he handles conflict.
Recently, Sherm and I had a difference of opinion on an issue.
And after the issue played out, we were emailing back and forth, and I decided to call Sherm.
But Sherm beat me to the punch.
He actually called me, and we had a great conversation.
As the call ended, it was evident to me that SHRM did not harbor any bad feelings, but his goal was to maintain the relationship.
Let me just say this.
This behavior is atypical for most of the executives that I work with.
They usually harbor these bad feelings and don't try to maintain the relationship.
SHRM is able to do that, which is a great trait for a speaker.
Second, his level-headedness.
In most instances in the past years, I've seen SHRM stay calm and composed in tough situations.
This can be difficult for some, but SHRM always stayed balanced in tough times.
Again, procedures on how the House works and what needs to get done for the House as well as New Hampshire constituents.
So in closing, based on these characteristics, I support SHRM, and I hope that you will too in vote for SHRM Packard for the next Speaker of the House.
Thank you, Mr.
Clark.
Representative Gorski seconds the nomination of Representative Packard.
The chair recognizes the member from Lenonderry, Representative Sherman Packard.
Thank you, Mr.
Clerk, and thank you for those words.
We've got two tough years ahead of us.
Philosophically, in many cases, we are going to have different opinions on subject matter.
I think that Representative Simpson and I disagree on that.
We are going to have a vast amount of difference on subject matter.
But by God, that doesn't mean we can't be civil and friendly and cooperate with each other when we are on the same page.
We do not need to do any name calling or any of that stuff.
I wish Twitter and Facebook didn't exist, because I think it would be better for our society.
But having said that, they do exist.
So all I ask of all of you on both sides of the aisle is that we respect each other.
And we make sure that we can have a civil conversation, and we can disagree, but we can still have that conversation.
My door is open.
It has been for the last four years since I've been speaker.
If anybody in this room wants to come and talk to me and I'm not tied up in a meeting, the door is open for you to come in, and that goes for both sides of the aisle.
I've had that open-door policy for for four years and I intend on keeping it.
I truly believe that as a body, we can get through the next two years.
We can do it civilly.
We can do what's best for the citizens of the state of New Hampshire.
Now we may disagree on that from my friends over here, but we can do it in a civil manner.
So all I'm asking everybody in this room is let's make sure that we are civil to each other, regardless of how we feel on a particular issue.
Thank you.
Representative Sherman Packard accepts the nomination.
With no further nominations, the chair declares nominations for speaker closed.
At this time, I would ask all members to please take their seats so that we can begin distributing ballots for the election of speaker.
As you can see, my staff here in the well is coming out to pass out ballots.
Please do not mark them until I have completed my instructions.
Balloting will be done by division.
When you have marked your ballot, please remain seated.
I will call each division up.
There are two ballots boxes in the front of the chamber and two in the back.
Number one is on your left near the chamber door and is for A through E, as clearly marked.
Number two is in the back and to the right and is for F through L.
Number three is in the back on the left is for M through P and number four is on your right in the front designated as Q through Z.
It is important that you use the correct ballot box.
Staff members from the House Clerk's Office and Republican and Democratic offices will be stationed at each box.
Before you deposit your ballot in the box, please clearly state your name so the staff person may check your name off.
For the ease of traffic flow in the front and the back, please do not leave your seat until your division is called, and then please return to your seat via an aisle away from your division.
The staff of the clerk's office and the Republican and Democratic offices will be thus.
For boxes A through E is Paul Bryant and Slate Goodwin.
Box two F through L is Michael Ko and Dan Mason.
Box three is Theresa Preston and Rachel Potter.
And down here is Tracy Blanchard and Sean Connor.
After you have cast your vote and when I declare the ballot closed, the two ballot boxes in the rear will be coming down to the front.
the front.
At that point, tellers for Representatives Packard and Simpson and also two appointed by the chair will come down.
Representative Packard has designated representatives Fred Doucette and Joe Sweeney.
Representative Simpson has designated representatives Mary Haken Phillips and Nicholas Germana.
So one will be at each box.
The members will do the counting.
And the chair appoints the youngest members from the prior session as chair tellers, and that is Representatives McDonnell and Wheeler.
If members need assistance in casting their ballots, please raise your hand.
I will come and retrieve the ballot for you and cast your ballot.
Got you.
Okay.
So I will have the staff head to the boxes, please.
Thank you.
Okay.
So I will have the staff head to the boxes, please.
The staff will stand behind the boxes.
No ballots.
Okay.
Well, ballots will be forthcoming.
Let's get some ballots to them.
Thank you.
Have all members received a ballot?
Very good.
All right.
I am going to collect ballots for those folks that need them, so please just hold your hand up.
I will come and do that now.
And then I will call up the divisions.
Gracias.
Thank you.
Representative Jess Evans.
Gracias.
Have all those that needed assistance been able to cast a ballot?
You need a ballot?
I hereby declare the ballot closed.
At this time, see, this is the fun time, because I have to choose who goes and who doesn't, and some people get mad, and I still have to get elected by you, so I don't want to make any bad.
This time, please, as I mentioned, make note of the boxes and where they are.
This time I will call Division 3 to cast next one.
I'm going to take a look at the camera.
Thank you.
.
After you have cast your ballot, please return to your seats.
Thank you.
Vielen Dank.
.
This time I would ask Division 4 to cast their ballots, and I would remind members to please return to your seats after you have cast your ballot.
Thank you.
Maybe we'll cross.
Gracias.
Thank you.
Vielen Dank.
Gracias.
.
Members are reminded to please return to your seats and not clog the aisles so that more divisions can be called to vote.
Thank you.
At this time, I would ask Division 2 to cast their ballots, please.
which one's which Thank you.
Thank you.
Again, a reminder, please clear the aisles once you have voted so that other members may proceed to the ballot box.
At this time, I would like Divisions 1 and 5 to please cast their ballots.
Good to see you.
Thank you.
That's your first rodeo.
.
Thank you.
Enjoy your day.
.
Have all members cast their ballots.
You have 30 seconds to make your way to the ballot box before I close the ballot.
Cornell needs the vote.
Who?
Cornell.
Thank you.
.
With all members having cast their ballots, I hereby...
Now, with all members having cast their ballots, I declare the balloting closed.
Will the staff in the rear please bring the ballot boxes forward?
Ladies and gentlemen, if you need to have conversations, please remove yourself to the ante room while I give instructions.
I'm not afraid to use the gavel.
Ladies and gentlemen, at this time to my left, if representatives Haken Phillips, Doucette and Wheeler can come down please over here.
Representative Doucette, you can go across or not.
Good man.
And to my right, representatives Sweeney, Germana, and McDonald.
If you can make yourselves available over here, please.
The boxes themselves, so I see a gaggle of people around some boxes over here.
Please remove yourselves kindly.
Deputy speakers included.
The counters will be the members.
Thank you.
The other staff is free to dissipate.
So the members will count and tally.
There should be no members, the members that are counting, there should not be any cell phones taking pictures or notepads or anything of the sort.
Representative Wheeler, there should be no notepads from you.
My staff will handle the count.
We will proceed to count.
While you are all here and attentively listening, I have a message from the Senate.
The Senate has organized and elected its officers.
As President of the Senate, Senator Sharon M.
Carson.
As Clerk of the Senate, Tammy Wright.
We have to read that.
That's a formality.
Thank you.
.
Gracias.
Thank you.
That's a vote.
Gracias.
Thank you.
Vielen Dank.
Gracias.
Thank you.
Members will take their seats.
I have results, so please take your seats.
Karen.
Thank you.
The House will be in order.
Just for clarity's sake, the intention is to continue session until we are finished.
There's a reception afterward so you can get some food there.
388 votes were cast, 195 being necessary to win.
There are seven blank ballots.
There are 17 scatter ballots.
There were 162 ballots cast for Representative Alexis Simpson and The Chair recognizes Representative Simpson.
Mr.
Chair, I move that we cast one ballot unanimously for Speaker Sherm Packard.
Representative Alexis Simpson makes a motion that the ballot be declared for Speaker Packard unanimously.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
All those opposed nay.
The ayes have it.
The acting sergeant at arms will escort the speaker to the rostrum.
Thank you.
We have to find parking places for all of you.
We have to find committees for all of you.
And that's just the beginning.
So that's what we're going to be doing for the next month solid, is working on all these things and get you all ready to go.
What I said before in my acceptance speech is what I truly believe and what I intend on governing by.
So with that, let's move on.
So I guess we have a reception afterwards at some point?
Some point.
The House will come to order.
The House will proceed with the election of the House officers.
Nominations for clerk.
Nominations for the position of House clerk are in the order.
Representative Jennifer Rode nominates Paul C.
Smith for clerk of the house.
Representative Nicholas Germana seconds the nomination.
Are there any further nominations?
There being none, Representative Marjorie Smith's move that the nominations be closed and one ballot cast for Paul C.
Smith and declare him the duly elected clerk for the House for the 2025-26 biennium.
Thank you all, but you didn't give me a chance to finish.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed nay.
The ayes have it.
And Paul C.
Smith is declared clerk of the House for the 2526 biennium.
Nominations for Sergeant-at-Arms.
Nominates for the position of Sergeant-at-Arms, and they are in the order of Representative Ken Weil and nominates J.B.
Cullen for the House Sergeant-at-Arms, and Representative Timothy Suse seconds the nomination.
Are there any further nominations?
There being none, Representative Gabby Grossman moves that the nominations be closed, one ballot cast for J.B.
Cullen, and declare him the duly elected Sergeant-at-Arms Thank you.
Are there any further nominations?
There being none, Representative Gabby Grossman moves that the nominations be closed, one ballot cast for J.B.
Cullen, and declare him the duly elected Sergeant-in-Arms for the House for 2526 biennium.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
Opposed, nay.
The ayes have it.
And J.B.
Cullen is declared Sergeant-in-Arms for the House 2526 bionis.
Would the clerk come up, please?
Raise your right hand and where appropriate state your name in town.
I, Paul C.
Smith of Hawkington, do solemnly swear that I will bear faith and true allegiance the United States of America and the state of New Hampshire, and will support the constitutions thereof.
And will support the constitutions thereof.
So help me God.
I, I, Paul Smith, do solemnly and sincerely, do solemnly and sincerely, swear and affirm, swear and affirm, that I will faithfully and impartially, that I will faithfully and impartially, discharge and perform all the duties incumbent on me as clerk of the house.
Okay.
Representative, no, that's it, yeah.
This sort of, you know, I haven't done this in two years, so, you know, give me a break.
To the best of my abilities, agreeable to the rules and regulations of the New Hampshire Constitution, and the laws of the state of New Hampshire, so help me God.
Well, that was a hell of a start.
Okay.
The joint convention will come to order.
Okay, see it wasn't really my fault this time.
The house will come to order.
Well now, no, that's, let's see.
Resolution to form joint convention.
Speaker, House will now attend to a resolution.
Clerk reads this resolution.
Mr.
Speaker, Representatives Smith and Simpson offer the following.
Resolve that the House inform the Honorable Senate it is organized and is ready to meet in a joint convention for the purpose of electing a Secretary of State and a State Treasurer.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed nay, you guys have it, and the resolution is adopted.
The House will tend to, okay.
They're gonna bring the chairs first.
All right, we got about a few minute break here.
They gotta bring chairs for the senators.
Thank you.
Gracias.
Vielen Dank.
Thank you.
Okay, good.
Perfect.
Okay, go.
No wait for the message.
I think they're ready.
Thank you.
Gracias.
Vielen Dank.
Thank you.
Gracias.
Vielen Dank.
Thank you.
Gracias.
I'm not the eight.
Thank you.
Vielen Dank.
Gracias.
Thank you.
The House will come to order.
Recognize the clerk for a Senate message.
Mr.
Speaker, the Senate has organized and is ready to meet with the House of Representatives in joint convention for the purpose of electing a Secretary of State and a State Treasurer.
Recognize the Clerk.
The Chair recognizes the Clerk.
Well, I thought we were ready.
Thank you.
Well, I thought we were ready, but...
The chair recognizes the clerk.
Mr.
Speaker, the honorable Senate.
Thank you.
Joint convention will come.
Recognize the clerk?
Mr.
Speaker, the President of the Senate constitutional officers of Secretary of State and State Treasurer.
Nominations for the Secretary of State are now in order.
The chair recognizes Senator from Hampstead, Senator Birdsill, for the purpose of making a nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker, and congratulations to you and the new House.
I'd like to place in nomination the name of David Scanlon for Secretary of State.
As a former chair of the Senate Election Law Committee, I've worked closely with Secretary Scanlon and his staff.
Secretary Scanlon is a trusted, nonpartisan resource for the legislature and for our communities.
His team is one of the best in the state government.
Their work results in elections that run smoothly, have some of the highest turnouts in the country, and have the public's trust.
However, the Secretary of State's office does much more than just elections.
They have a whole host of responsibilities, include working in the areas of administration where it houses information on the governor and council, lobbyists, New Hampshire's Canadian Trade Council, the right to know ombudsman, and our ethics.
They have a corporate division which maintains the New Hampshire State Registry of Corporations and provides accessible, transparent services that support the growth of New Hampshire's business environment.
The office also manages our Uniform Commercial Code Statutory Liens.
This department is a registry that serves the commercial lending and banking community.
It manages security regulations through the Bureau of Securities and Regulations, and their mission is to create equitable regulations for the protection of New Hampshire investors, as well as facilitating responsible capital formations of this state.
The Secretary of State's Office also manages New Hampshire's archives and records, where they preserve documents of the history of the New Hampshire state government and help state agencies with their proper management of their historical documents.
The Secretary of State also manages all of our vital records, which keeps track of births and deaths throughout the state.
As you can see, the Secretary of State's office does so much more than just elections.
And in order to manage these processes, we need someone with a steady hand, deep experience, and who is trusted to work in a nonpartisan manner.
And lastly, because if you've ever been in their office during the summer, Secretary Scanlon was someone who was able to put air conditioning in that office.
He has all of these characteristics and much more.
David Scanlon is the right person for the job.
I wholeheartedly support him for Secretary of State and hope you will join me in supporting him today.
Thank you.
Senator Berzio nominates David M.
Scanlon for Secretary of State.
Presidents Leachman and McDonald second the nomination of David M.
Are there further nominations?
There being none, Senator Bursil moves that the nominations be closed, one ballot cast for David M.
Scanlon, and declare him the duly elected Secretary of State for the 2025-2026 biennium.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
I suppose nay.
The ayes have it.
And David M.
Scanlon is declared the Secretary of State for the 2025-2026 biennium.
.
Congratulations to you.
Well, thank all of you for this great honor.
It's a big job.
As Senator Birdsell said, it is a state agency that the Secretary of State has to run.
I appreciate her nomination and the seconds of Representative Leishman and McDonald.
You know, the secretary is only as good as the people that work for him and the staff, so I have to give a big thank you to my deputies, Erin Hennessey and Patty Lovejoy.
They're fantastic, and I hope you have the opportunity to work with them.
And then I can't say enough about the staff in the department, in all of the divisions.
We have employees that really step up, and hopefully you get to work with them on a day-to-day basis.
They do tremendous work, and I'm really, really proud of each and every one of them.
In terms of accomplishments over the last two years, the department has been very busy.
We've had a lot of successes, but the largest one is the preserving the first in the nation presidential primary, which is something that everybody in this room gets behind.
We face the largest challenge to that primary in the primary's history.
And I think the aftermath of that is that it is still as relevant as it ever has been.
And I look forward to when we do it again in 2028.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker, Madam President.
I rise to nominate Monica Mazzopelli to again be treasurer of the state of New Hampshire.
This is a critical role for the financial management of our state.
She brings a background of financial management in New Hampshire government for the last 24 years.
As treasurer, she is a member on several boards and authorities.
I serve with her on the College Tuition Savings Plan Advisory Commission.
She serves on the Retirement Board, Municipal Bond Bank Board, Deferred Compensation Plan Commission, and several others.
She's a key advisor to both the House and Senate Ways and Means Committee and the House and Senate Finance Committees.
She's brought us record returns on the investment of state funds and has brought us two credit rating upgrades in the last two years.
That's important in achieving low rates for borrowing.
She's responsible for issuing all the state government checks, both for payroll and services, and she carefully deals with the banks that are near where our employees live so that they can cash their checks in a neighborhood where they live and not have to pay a charge.
I could go on and on describing all the roles that Treasurer Mezapelli plays, but I can assure you from my 30 years of doing budgets, she can keep all the various functions of our financial system in her mind without missing any detail.
If you want a good read, pick up the New Hampshire bond statement.
This is about 100 pages describing the economic and demographic details of our state.
She publishes it annually for the negotiations and issuance of New Hampshire bonds.
Please join with me in voting for Monica Mezopelli for New Hampshire State Treasurer and keep our finances in good hands.
Thank you.
Representative Ken Weil nominates Monica Mezzipelli for the State Treasurer.
The chair recognizes the Senator from Nashville, Senator Cindy Rosenwald, for the purpose of seconding the nomination.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker, and congratulations to you.
And it's great to be back in this chamber.
I, too, am pleased to support the nomination of Monica Mezzipelli for state treasurer.
She has held this position for nearly five years, and for six years before that she was the deputy treasurer.
I echo much of what Representative Weiler said about her, but the role of treasurer is critically important to the health of New Hampshire's economy.
First, she's focused on the state's borrowing capacity, recommending to the legislature the amount that is appropriate for us to bond every two years.
Her sound professional judgment on borrowing has led to two upgrades in ratings, which will save the state millions in borrowing costs.
She's also responsible for investing and managing the state's cash reserves of over $2.5 billion.
She's been incredibly successful here with interest coming in $85 million ahead of plan for the last fiscal year and $46 million ahead of plan for the current year to date.
This is by far our best performing revenue source right now.
Further, as state treasurer, she's also responsible for oversight of municipal cash reserves through the public deposit investment pool.
This is worth over 600 million dollars right now.
Helps our cities and towns invest their own money to get the best returns.
And she oversees New Hampshire's college savings plan which many families depend on to send their children to college.
She's responsive to all legislators, not just those serving on finance and ways and means.
She's done a great job for the state, and I hope we will re-elect her.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
Senator Rosenwald seconds the nomination of Monica Mesapelli for the state treasurer.
Are there further nominations?
There being none, President Weiler moves that the nominations be closed.
One ballot cast for Monica Mesapelli and declare her the duly elected state treasurer for the 2025-2026 biennium.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
I suppose nay.
The ayes have it.
And Monica Mesapelli is declared State Treasurer.
I'd like to thank Representative Wilder and Senator Rosenwald for nominating me today.
It is a great honor to have their support and to hear the kind words and remarks.
It is also a great honor to be here before all of you today, to be in this chamber, and to receive the overwhelming support you provided me today.
I really thank you for electing me today and for giving me the opportunity to do this again for two more years.
The last four years have been the highlight of my professional life.
The challenges that we face during the pandemic and the benefits that we have received during the recovery have taught us many lessons.
I have certainly learned a lot.
And one of the key takeaways for me is the importance of being prepared, the need to assess risks and develop policies and plans that can guide us during good and also not so good times.
I'm really excited to continue this work and to continue building not only a more resilient treasury but to continue building a stronger state, a stronger economy and all for the benefit of all granted staters.
But clearly that's not a one job, so I look forward to collaborating with all of you to continue making this state the best state in the country.
And I want to be brief today, so before you go back to your business and your lunch, I would just like to take the opportunity to recognize the Treasury staff.
They are a wonderful, hardworking group of people who really care about their job and the citizens we serve.
I feel very honored I get to work with them every day.
And in closing, I just would like to remind you that my office is across the street.
I am only one email or phone call away.
Please do not hesitate to contact me.
I would love to assist you in any way I can.
And with that, I thank you again for your support today and for your trust, and I look forward to working together in this upcoming legislative session.
And congratulations to you all.
Thank you.
The joint convention will come to order.
I will now administer the oath of office to the Secretary of State and the State Treasurer.
Raise your right hand and where appropriate, state your name and town.
I, of, you solemnly swear, that I will bear faith and true allegiance to the United States of America, and the state of New Hampshire, and will support the constitutions thereof.
And will support the constitution thereof.
So help me God.
I.
Do solemnly swear.
Solemnly swear.
And sincerely affirm that I will faithfully.
And impartially discharge.
and perform all the duties incumbent on me.
Incumbent on me.
I according to the best of my abilities, agreeable to the rules, and regulations of the Constitution, and laws of the state of New Hampshire, so help me God.
So help me God.
Congratulations.
Thank you very much.
The Senator from Hampstead, Senator Birdshill, and the member from Charlestown, Representative Stephen Smith, move that the joint convention arise.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed nay, the ayes have it.
The joint convention is adjourned.
The House is still in session.
Thank you.
The House will come to order.
The House will attend to a resolution.
Mr.
Speaker, Representative Stephen Smith and Simpson offer the following.
Resolve that the House adopt the rules of the 2024 session for the 2025-26 biennium.
Representative Stephen Smith orders a floor amendment to House Resolution 1, located in your seat pockets.
The Chair recognizes Representative Stephen Smith.
This amendment contains a change to the standing committees of the House.
There's two changes.
One new standing committee on housing is created.
I think both sides want this.
I know the public wants us to do it.
I attended a housing symposium years ago that was a bipartisan affair.
Then Governor Hassan was there.
And one of the outputs of that meeting was where they broke out in the work sessions that they wanted the House to have a housing committee.
So it's time we showed the public that we focus on it.
The other change is a splitting of the education committee.
Right now, rough count is about 120 bills headed to education.
If you would like to serve on education and be involved in that, but also do not want to live here four days a week, vote for this rules change.
One committee will focus primarily on funding, and the other one will focus on policy and administration.
There is also a hope that by separating those two issues, the policy and administration can be far more contentious than the funding that maybe will actually beat the courts to getting to a solution and save face for the House.
So, to serve more of you better, a lot of you asked to be on education, you don't get it because there's only 20 slots.
This will create more opportunity to serve on that committee.
So hopefully you will agree that this will serve you better, lighten your workload, and serve the public.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
The question is on the adoption of the floor amendment to House Resolution No.
1.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed nay.
The ayes have it, and the amendment is adopted.
The question now is on the adoption of the resolution.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed nay.
The ayes have it, and the resolution is adopted.
The House will attend to a further resolution.
Mr.
Speaker, Representatives Stephen Smith and Simpson offer the fall and resolve that all action taken at all sessions of the House of Representatives be recorded through the public address system and that the recording be used by the clerk to confirm and correct the permanent journal.
The permanent journal as prepared by the clerk and as may be corrected by the House, shall be the official record of the House.
The question is on the adoption of the resolution.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Those oppose nay.
The ayes have it.
The resolution is adopted.
The House will attend to a further resolution.
Mr.
Speaker, Representative Stephen Smith and Simpson offer the following.
Resolved that the following policy be established for the distribution of House calendars and journals, bills and resolutions to members of the General Court and State Departments.
Number one, every citizen is entitled to free of charge to one copy of any publication at the legislative counter or to have the publication mailed to that person upon individual request for one such copy.
Two, persons requesting copies for the entire session will be charged a fee sufficient to cover postage, envelopes, and handling.
Such fees may be prorated when services received for portions of the session only.
All fees are payable in advance.
The subscriber list may be submitted for legislative accounting and auditing purpose, but is not for publication or sale.
Three, all fees charged for publications in accordance with this resolution shall be fixed with the approval of the Speaker, paid into the State Treasury and credited to the legislative appropriation.
The questions on the adoption of the resolution, are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed nay, the ayes have it and the resolution is adopted.
The House will attend to a further resolution.
Mr.
Speaker, Representative Stephen Smith and Simpson offer the following.
Resolve that the Speaker may employ such personnel as he may deem necessary and with the approval of the House Subcommittee on the Committee on Legislative Facilities may fix their compensation in accordance with RSA 17-E-5.
The question is on the adoption of the resolution.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
The ayes have it and the resolution is adopted.
I also attend to a further resolution.
Mr.
Speaker, Representative Stephen Smith and Simpson offer the following.
Resolve that the members will be paid their legislative salary as provided in the Constitution in the month of January 2025 and that mileage of members of the House of Representatives be paid every two weeks during the session.
The questions on the adoption of the resolution are I ready for the question.
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
As opposed, nay.
The ayes have it and the resolution is adopted.
The House will now attend to an amendment to the ethics guidelines as printed in the House calendar.
For what reason does the member rise?
To make a motion.
Stage a motion.
I move to special order the ethics amendment to the next House session as regular place in the calendar.
The motion is in order.
I have heard from many people that there is significant changes in this, and due to all the other business that we have had today, I have not yet had the time to thoroughly analyze them, and therefore would ask that we special order it to our next session, the first session in January, so that we can have the time to study it and speak to it as of appropriate after that study.
Thank you.
Jared.
Chairman.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
I rise to second the motion.
And if I may, I would like to echo all of those sentiments, and I think we've all seen recently that how important ethics rules are, how they really will govern our activities to a significant degree over the next two years.
We've seen that not only are they important, but if they're not just right, they can be done wrong with.
So we want to take a little extra time, if you would agree, we need three-fifths vote for this, to achieve that.
Please vote yes.
Thank you.
The motion before us is to special order the ethics guideline amendment to January 8th.
Chair recognizes Representative Lynn.
Colleagues, I guess I'm not sure candidly that I oppose this, but I want to raise several issues that I think we need to think about.
First of all, until just now, there was no issue raised, at least with me and I believe with other members of of the committee about this issue.
With one exception.
The member will suspend.
Yeah, I'm not sure who yelled out like that, but that is completely inappropriate.
The member may continue.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
With one exception, I had a call about a week ago from a freshman representative.
I have to apologize.
I frankly don't remember his name now.
But we had a long discussion about his concern about a particular section of the ethics guidelines.
We had a long discussion.
I told him that my view was he raised a concern about whether if somebody was an advocate for an organization, but not an advocate before the legislature, would that require the person to recuse from participating?
And basically what I said to the person is, first of all, I can't speak for the Ethics Committee, but just speaking sort of as a general of what my thoughts were on it, that it would depend on the circumstances.
That was the only issue that was raised, and more importantly, the objection that this member raised, although he said I raise it to the guidelines, the problem is that the guidelines section in question mirrors the statute that we passed last year.
So it's in the law.
We can't change that unless we want to change the law.
The practical considerations I have with postponing this are this.
As I understand it from the clerk, and he can speak to this much more eloquently than I can, I'm sure.
If we don't act on this now, this means we have to act on it on January 8th.
And the problem with that, I think there are several problems with that.
We're not going to be here again until January 8th, and so that would mean that the Ethics Committee would have to meet and propose some language between now and January 8th.
For me, that's not a problem, but I can't speak for the Ethics Committee, and there are people on the Ethics Committee—first of all, this is December, it's the holiday season—there are people on the Ethics Committee who are, for example, former legislators.
I don't know their availability, but more importantly for this body, the thing I see as a problem is, what's going to happen?
Let's suppose that some changes were proposed to the ethics guidelines.
That means you're going to get them on January 8th and then be expected to vote on them on January 8th?
I just don't see the sense in doing this.
I will tell you that the Ethics Committee voted unanimously to adopt the guidelines which track the language in the statute.
So I'm not quite sure what we're going to change that we would have the power to change unless we were going to change legislation.
Now, one other thing that I should mention, there is language in the guidelines dealing with the sexual harassment policy.
If you look at that language, you will see that in addition to sort of prescribing sexual harassment, it has broader language that deals generally with harassment.
The point I would make there is that that is something that has been in the ethics guidelines for a long time.
Apparently, it was adopted by the Facilities Commission, the committee, if I recall correctly, Mr.
Speaker.
This was long before my time.
But anyway, it's been in the guidelines for a long time.
So in terms of the substance, even as to that, we didn't change anything with regard to the substance.
So I guess what I, the bottom line is this.
if this body thinks that we should put it off till January 8th, I guess fine we'll put it off to January 8th.
I'm not sure what we're going to accomplish by that given, you know, given what's already happened.
So thank you Mr.
Speaker.
Does the member yield to questions?
I do.
Member yields Representative Splane Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
Thank you to the member for taking my question.
It's my understanding, based on the timetable, that we still have the ability to make changes to the rules on January 8th with amendments and or beyond that with just a majority vote until the end of December if we were to do so again.
However, the 8th is the only scheduled time we'll be meeting, so it seems to be the only practical time.
My question is, if we were to pass this today, could members not bring amendments on the 8th and then put those amendments to the body on the 8th.
So, again, I'm taking my cue from the clerk here.
Members cannot make amendments to the ethics rules.
It would have to come from the ethics committee.
Again, in some sense, this is sort of a process issue.
If there had been some issues raised earlier that the ethics committee could have dealt with, we would have addressed them.
But, I mean, assuming we could, and again, as I say, these ethics guidelines are taken from the statute.
So, you know, we did make, we all voted on, both this body and the other body, voted on significant changes to the ethics rules, which the ethics rules will now require recusal in certain cases as covered by the rules.
That's a big change.
There's no question about it.
But we passed that.
And, you know, we can't sort of adopt ethics rules that say, well, you know, you don't have to follow what's in the statute.
We can't do that.
So, again, I say, if you and your wisdom think we should wait until January 8th, I guess we can do that.
I'm really concerned about the fact that we're, on January 8th, we're going to be in no better position than we are today.
Does the member yield to a follow-up question?
I do.
Governor McLean.
Thank you again, Mr.
Speaker.
Thank you again to the member for taking my question.
So if I understand correctly, the members themselves cannot propose the amendments, but if we pass this today, there's nothing that stops the ethics committee from proposing another revision on the 8th if members come to the Ethics Committee and the Ethics Committee passes it between now and the 8th.
Is that correct?
Yes, I believe that is correct.
Does the member yield a further question?
I do.
Representative Smith, you may require.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
You had no choice, did you?
I'm really confused.
The gentleman who proposed this motion indicated that he had just gotten this and he hadn't had time to review it.
If I remember correctly, and I might be wrong, the calendar came out earlier than usual last week because of the holiday and therefore every member of the house had access to this either Tuesday or Wednesday of last week, which was a week ago.
And therefore, I know I had 25 for Thanksgiving dinner and I'm still doing the laundry, but I had time to read it.
And I would assume if you thought it was important, you would have read it.
I don't really think that it's legitimate to say that we were blindsided.
We weren't.
We've had it.
We've had it for a week.
And I would think we ought to get on with our business.
Oh, you're absolutely right.
I forgot that.
My question is, am I wrong in when we were notified?
And I'd like to thank my colleague for putting me on the right track.
That is an excellent question, Representative.
I think you are not wrong.
The only other thing that I would say is, please understand that the Ethics Committee did go through these guidelines really sort of line by line, and there were a number of, you know, changes to the guidelines we made to make them consistent with the statute.
So I guess what I want to say to you is the Ethics Committee, you know, this wasn't, we didn't just sort of get this and say, okay, let's just vote.
And we spent some time on this.
I'm sorry.
We spent some time on this.
And that's not to say that, you know, that it couldn't be made better.
I'm not going to say that, you know, sit here and say that.
But what I am saying is for the reasons I've stated before, I'm not really sure how we would advance the ball by delaying this, particularly to the extent that people have, are basically saying change the guidelines to make them inconsistent with the statute.
We just can't, we can't do that.
The Ethics Committee doesn't have any authority to do that.
We would have to have a new bill to do that.
Thank you.
Do you recognize Representative Perez?
I think the point has been missed here.
I think the reason why people want to delay this is so that they have an opportunity to read it.
I understand that it came out a week ago, a little ahead of time, but people had family, they had the holiday.
Not everybody had the opportunity to sit down, read, and absorb this.
So I don't understand why not a lot putting it off for a vote instead of worrying about you know this amendment and that and this and that maybe nobody heard about it because they didn't have heard questions or put questions out about it is because they didn't have time to read it.
Thank you.
Chair, can I, Chair, can I represent you McFarland?
For what reason do you?
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
I rise for a parliamentary inquiry.
State your inquiry.
I would like to ask the clerk further to the questions that were posed to Representative Lynn and further to the understanding that Representative Lynn provided us that an amendment could be provided to us additionally to the existing amendment on January 8th so that we would have a further amendment from the Ethics Committee before us.
My question of the Clerk is does he concur with that understanding and does he believe that if there is a significant number of representatives who may appear before the Rules Committee and before the Ethics Committee between now and January the 8th with the expectation that the Rules Committee and the Ethics Committee can discuss presenting a further amendment that would not be in contravention of the statutes enacted by HB 1388, but would further clarify them and would provide additional guidance within the guidelines that we are seeking to amend.
Would those actions be in order, and would it then be in order for us to vote for this motion to special order the current amendment?
Well, he won't give us an opinion on voting, but he'll try and answer your other question.
Thank you, sir.
Chair, recognize the clerk.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
Just for clarity, the clerk doesn't usually answer parliamentary inquiries.
The chair does that.
That being said, there are some specific questions that you asked relative to House rules versus the ethics guidelines.
House rules are separate from the Ethics Committee process.
The Ethics Committee is bound by statute to present their guidelines to the House, and the House, and the House has three House days, meaning three House session days, in which to adopt or vote down those guidelines.
Additionally, the Senate likewise has to do the same thing.
The issue here is that today is day one.
The eighth is day two.
Day three, technically, would be the ninth, which is essentially exclusively reserved for the governor's inaugural.
We pro forma come into session on the ninth, but it is really not, and has not been in my lifetime a voting day where we take up additional legislative activity.
In order to special order this measure to the 8th, it would take three-fifths.
That is pursuant to our House rules.
In terms of amendments coming from the Ethics Committee, the Ethics Committee must be reformed.
A new Ethics Committee has to be established by the new administration.
That consists of two members of the House, a member of the majority and the minority, two members of the Senate, a member of the majority and minority.
The Speaker appoints a member of the public, the Senate President appoints a member of the public, and then they jointly choose a chair.
That is on the list for appointments that need to happen, much like the Administrative Rules Committee and our House Rules Committee that hopefully will be appointed within the month, but the likelihood of that happening and our noticing for calendar to have not only a meeting scheduled but an appointment and also new guidelines adopted by said committee because the committee process is that they take those guidelines that they are presented, they discuss them, they have time to digest, and then they put them forward to the two respective bodies.
So the short answer is yes, these can be amended today, these can be amended the 8th, and subsequent amendments from the Ethics Committee can come.
The reason they cannot be amended, these can be amended by members of the House, is that this is essentially a report of a body that has to be adopted, similar to a Committee of Conference report.
It is either an upvote or a downvote.
And then they have to go back to the drawing board.
Does that answer your question, sir?
It does.
Thank you.
And if I may ask one final question to the Chair, am I correct in understanding that if this were a motion to table rather than a motion to special order, that it would be a simple majority?
Yes, correct.
Thank you.
Representative Weber.
Thank you, and thank you for taking my question.
My question is simply, if any member has any question about their obligations under these ethics guidelines if we are to adopt them, do they not have the opportunity to present that question to the ethics committee with all of their own specific circumstances so that the ethics committee may give that member a ruling on the guidelines and also that that ruling then stands as guidelines for other members so the guidelines could be fleshed out as time goes on.
That's correct.
Yes.
What purpose does a member rise?
Ask a question, Mr.
Speaker.
Ask away.
So my question, Mr.
Speaker, is for us freshman representatives who got our packets yesterday and have not had access to email and have not had access to review this policy and understand it thoroughly, who were briefed on the existing policy before these changes during orientation, are we expected to vote in favor?
Are we to vote for changing policy that we haven't read today, Mr.
Speaker?
How you vote is totally up to you.
Representative Roy.
What purpose does a member rise?
To ask a question of the committee.
Go ahead.
The question is regarding the definition of compensation and the definition of entity.
Many of us in here belong to a variety of nonprofit organizations.
Some of us hold positions in that.
Representative, the motion before us is to special order.
Yeah, and this goes to that question because if the definition isn't recognized, it will change some people's votes.
Therefore, that particular entity, the definition of compensation, I think, is essential to determining whether or not a vote should be taken, one way or another.
May I continue?
I'm not going to get into answering questions.
No.
So the question is, if we vote to continue it, would that give the Ethics Committee a chance to further define what compensation is and whether or not compensation includes payment of incidentals and costs of those persons who provide services to a nonprofit.
That would be up to the ethics committee to make that determination.
I'm not going to sit here and try to find it.
Very good, sir.
Thank you.
Wait a minute.
Okay.
Senator Verville.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker, and congratulations.
Just a quick parliamentary question.
as a friendly reminder to myself, my colleagues, and maybe to inform the freshman members.
Is it not a breach of etiquette to call another member by their name from the well?
Is that correct?
That is not recommended.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
For what reason does the member rise?
I would like to make a motion to table this.
A motion to table is a higher motion so the motion before is to table the amendment for the ethics guidelines.
Are you ready for the question?
Well, the only way a division can happen is if it's a standing division.
You can't use the machines because it's not your assigned seat that will be going into the session.
So the motion has been withdrawn.
So the motion is to table.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Chair is in doubt.
We'll have a standing.
All right.
Everybody must stay in their seats.
Paul, you have four, you have three, and I have two more.
The staff, everybody that said aye will stand.
We sit, Representative.
Until you're counted and told to sit down.
All those voting yes.
All those voting aye, stand.
Thank you.
until you're counted and told to sit down.
All those voting aye, stand.
The question is on the tabling motion.
Thank you.
Did you count?
Yeah, so.
Division, you can sit.
You can sit.
All right, so 45 for those three divisions.
So Division 5 is 3, 5 is all sports.
All the nays, please rise and stay standing until you're counted.
Gracias.
Thank you.
We're all set.
We had 242 voting nay.
We had 106 voting nay.
The motion fails.
We're back to the question of special order.
This is a three-fifth vote.
I guess, are you ready for the question?
Okay.
Thank you.
Seeing that this has to be a three-fifths motion, if I pass by three-fifths, there, there's no way I think I can, or any one of us in this chamber can honestly determine whether it's three-fifths or not.
So we're going to go to a standing.
You withdraw.
Okay.
Withdrawing the motions.
Okay, the question is now on the adoption of the ethics guidelines are you ready for the question all those in favor say aye those opposed nay when the amendment is adopted.
The chair recognizes the member from Charlestown, Representative Stephen Smith for the third reading motion.
Resolved that the house now adjourned from the early session, that the business of the late session be in order at the present time, the present time, that the readings of resolutions be by caption only, and that all resolutions be read a third time.
House adjourned from the early session, that the late session be in order at the present time, that the readings and resolutions be by caption only, and that all resolutions be read a third time and passed when the House adjourns today, it be to convene on Wednesday, January 28th.
Yeah?
Okay.
How about Wednesday, January 8th, 2025 at any particular time?
Thank you.
Yeah?
Okay.
How about Wednesday, January 8th, 2025 at any particular time?
The question is on the third reading motion.
Are you ready for the question?
All those in favor say aye.
Opposed, nay.
The ayes have it.
The motion is adopted.
The House will attend to announcements.
Chair recognizes Representative Megan Murray.
Thank you, Mr.
Clerk.
Pursuant to RSA 24, 9-A, the Hillsborough County Convention organizational meeting will be held on Wednesday, December 11, 2024 at 5pm the committee.
The committee will be approved by the committee.
The committee willNA and LPN program pursuant to RSA 273-A to consider the approval of the memorandum of an agreement between HCDOC and AFSCME Local 3657 and a memorandum of agreement between HCDOC and NECU Local 128 for a limited staffing hiring and referral program and any other business to come before the delegation.
Thank you.
Chair recognize Representative Petuchak.
Thank you Mr.
Speaker.
I'm here to announce the organizational meeting at the state house.
There will be an organization meeting of Rockingham County delegates.
If you are a rep from Rockingham County somewhere, you are part of the Rockingham County Convention.
It's on 12-11 at 10 a.m.
to elect officers and an executive committee and to adopt resolutions.
A quorum is required.
You are paid mileage and you are fed.
Thank you.
Chair recognizes Representative Rhodes.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
Mr.
Speaker, she and Finney Capital, cordially invite all of you and all of you to Tandy's at 1.30 to welcome us all back.
Congratulations.
Chair, I recognize Representative Tulurski.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
Before you go to Tandy's, go downstairs to meet New Hampshire Hunger Solutions who will have coffee and pastries so you can learn more about food access here in the Granite State.
Thank you.
Chair recognizes Representative Davis.
Thank you Mr.
Speaker.
The Coas County delegation, we have a meeting in Stewartstown next Wednesday the 13th at 10 o'clock.
Thank you.
The 11th, sorry.
Chair recognize Representative Seaworth.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
To the Republican members of the Merrimack County delegation, will be having a brief caucus downstairs in State House Rooms 122 and 123 to discuss the meetings that we have over the next week.
Finally, if any Republican member of that caucus has not been receiving emails from me, let me know so we know that we can contact you thank you very much thank you mr.
speaker so for the Stratford County delegation you should already have received notification but this is just a reminder we will organize next Wednesday at 7 p.m.
at the county building as usual.
Next Wednesday.
Stratford County only.
Thank you.
Chair recognize Representative Rowley for announcements.
Republicans from Hillsborough County, please pay attention to an email you'll be getting.
There will be a caucus on the 10th by Zoom.
Thank you.
Chair recognize the the clerk.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
A couple of quick announcements for you.
One, for all new members, if you did not check your mailboxes right behind the chamber before session, you will find some goodies in your boxes.
You will have your name tags and some other stuff.
All members are invited after the session to get your new security pin in the ante room.
Tracy is back there with a checklist.
For those of you who want more than one, I know who you are.
You get one unless it breaks.
So please sign in and get your pin.
Next, your portal forms.
If you have not done your portal forms, please do them.
If you need help with your portal forms, please stop in GCAO, the administrative office downstairs on the first floor.
It is important that we get your committee choices.
Right now I've only received about 260 out of 399, so I need to hear from you, please.
Lastly, you all need to sign the computer use policy form.
Folks from GCTS, General Corps Technology Services, are also in the ante room.
If you want your legislative email, if you would like to have a presence on the website, you need to sign the computer use policy.
So please do that.
Thank you.
The organizational session of 2025-2026.
We do for delaying everyone's lunch a bit more.
Is this all right?
Awesome.
I apologize for delaying everyone's lunch a little bit more, but I rise today to commemorate a program that is near and dear to my heart.
As the youngest member of this esteemed body, I recognize that I would not be standing before you in this chamber if it weren't for a robust civics education that gave me the knowledge and confidence to throw my hat into the political ring.
Unfortunately, that was not wholly provided to me in public school.
I had to search elsewhere for it.
To compensate for and to broaden my experience, I joined the legislative youth advisory Council in 2021, appointed by you, Mr.
Speaker, which opened my world to so many more political and civic opportunities that I had previously not been aware of.
One of these programs was the United States Senate Youth Program, established by U.S.
Senate Resolution 324 in 1962, stating that, quote, the continued vitality of our republic depends in part on the intelligent understanding of our political processes and the functions of our national government by the citizens of the United States.
Every year, every state, as well as the District of Columbia and the Department of Defense Education Activity, selects two high school juniors or seniors to represent them during a week-long trip to D.C., meeting with senators, cabinet officials, Supreme Court justices, and often the President of the United States.
In addition to this, every delegate receives a $10,000 undergraduate scholarship.
Exactly a year ago Sunday, Mr.
Speaker, I was selected to represent our great state of New Hampshire in the 62nd annual program during March of this year, alongside my friend Mr.
Michael Blair of Manchester.
During this program, we got to meet 102 other incredible delegates from across the country, as well as seeing everything from the Pentagon to the White House on the night of the State of the Union.
After I returned home from D.C., I received an unexpected letter from a former member of this House, the Honorable Stephen Dupree, congratulating me on my selection for the program.
He explained that he was selected as a delegate in 1971, and next year he ran for and won a seat in this body, at the time the youngest person to do so.
While I may not agree with the Honorable Former Representative on Everything, it highlights that this program and others like it bridge generations, ideologies, parties, life experiences, and regions.
I've been able to meet people from across the country with whom I vehemently disagree while still being dear friends.
That sort of civil disagreement is at the heart of the political discourse we need to return to as a state and nation for the prosperity of our country's future.
It also drives alumni to be more involved and gives them knowledge and experience to make an impact in their communities, whether in elected office, like Mr.
Dupree or myself, or as private citizens advocating for change.
I'm honored, therefore, as a former delegate and a member of this body, to pass the baton and congratulate the New Hampshire delegates to the 63rd annual United States Senate Youth Program.
Mr.
William Brochu and Mr.
Ryan Casey of Concord, both of whom are here today in the gallery.
Mr.
Brochu is a junior at Brewster Academy, where he's class president.
He entered for governor-elect Ayotte's campaign and works for his family's landscaping and construction businesses.
In his spare time, he volunteers with the Special Olympics in his church's local food pantry.
Mr.
Casey is a junior at Bishop Brady, where he's also class president and captain of the math team, science Olympiad, and soccer team.
He also volunteers at the McAuliffe Shepherd Discovery Center and Sycamore Community Garden, while also coaching the middle school math team.
How I wish I had that kind of time.
I'm blown away by the accomplishments and involvement of these two, and I couldn't be more pleased to welcome them into the Senate youth family to succeed Mr.
Blair and I.
I'd also like to congratulate Mr.
Anthony Henry of Derry and Ms.
Aubrey Herzog of Claremont for their selection as alternates.
As a student school board member and a New Hampshire youth governor, respectively, their dedication to civic engagement in New Hampshire is truly admirable.
Mr.
Speaker, I know there are sometimes tensions with the chamber on the other side of the wall, but I concur with former Franklin resident Senator Daniel Webster in believing that, quote, it is fortunate there is a Senate of the United States, a body not yet moved from its propriety, not lost to a just sense of its own dignity, and in its own high responsibilities, a body to which the country looks with confidence for wise, moderate, and patriotic healing councils.
I take these words to heart and strive for my own service to reflect these principles, and I encourage these fine gentlemen to do the same as they embark on their journey to Washington.
I sincerely hope that they come to learn what makes the Senate such a unique, deliberative body in the spirit of Senator Webster's words, navigating them towards a bright future of public service.
My best advice for them would be to meet as many people as possible with whom they disagree and try their best to find common ground.
Often your closest friends made will be the ones with whom you agree the least, or so I found.
And perhaps there's a grain of truth in that for all of us in this chamber as well, Mr.
Speaker.
On that note, I would be remiss not to recognize my friends and fellow 2023 delegates who made the trip up today to view the New Hampshire political process in action.
And boy, did they get to experience that today.
Mr.
Joshua Blake of Louisiana, Mr.
Liam Drake of North Carolina, and Mr.
James Howard of Maryland, as well as any of the former delegates who may be watching online.
All of these delegates, past, present, and future, embody what it means to be civically engaged as young people and represent the future of our nation's political discourse.
Knowing them is an honor and has certainly driven me to strive to forever improve my public service.
I truly believe, Mr.
Speaker, that if these are the sort of people taking charge and leading, the vitality of our nation's future is strong.
Finally, I would like to thank Ms.
Rainey Guilford, the Director of the United States Senate Youth Program.
She has led the program since 2006 and is the reason it is what we have today.
She's retiring after the 2025 program, but for the last two decades, she and her team have shaped the lives of thousands of young people across our country, and should be commended for that.
And I wish her the best at whatever she does next.
I would also encourage each and every one of my colleagues to promote the Senate Youth Program and other civic opportunities like it in their constituencies, as well as supporting civic education reform to bolster the work that people like Ms.
Guilford have been doing for years.
If it's proper, Mr.
Speaker, I would ask my honorable colleagues to rise and give these delegates a hand for their hard work and dedication.
Would that be all right?
What?
If it's proper, Mr.
Speaker, I would ask my honorable colleagues to rise and give these delegates a hand for their hard work and dedication.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker.
I yield the floor and I would ask for my remarks to be printed in the record.
The organizational session of 2025-2026, House of Representatives, is adjourned.
Thank you.